und dann hat diese woche auch noch die
gerechtigkeit gesiegt der
bundesgerichtshof in karlsruhe stellt im
fall volkswagen höchstrichterlich fest
der absichtliche software betrug durch
volkswagen war absicht ja schön dass das
jetzt mal geklärt ist hat lange genug
gedauert
manche behaupten ja jura wäre so
wahnsinnig kompliziert aber manchmal ist
es halt auch erfreulich simpel wer in
einer gegen die guten sitten
verstoßenden weise einem anderen
vorsätzlich schaden zufügt ist dem
anderen zum ersatz des schadens
verpflichtet
ja vw hat so die richter vorsätzlich und
sittenwidrig gehandelt das heißt ich
darf jetzt ganz offiziell sagen in
diesem laden arbeiten sitten streiche ja
der kläger kriegt den neuwert seines
autos zurück - nutzungs pauschale
übrigens hätte der konzern selber viel
früher vor den bgh ziehen können sie
haben aber lieber jahrelang auf unteren
instanzen vergleiche abgeschlossen und
jetzt blöde sache gucken die 75 prozent
der geschädigten die nicht geklagt haben
in die röhre
ja verjährt verjährt so bitter so bitter
denn eigentlich waren die wesentlichen
fakten alle schon 2015 bekannt vw chef
martin winterkorn habe angerufen und
gefragt was ist mit den dieseln in den
usa los am anderen ende der leitung
bernd gottweis ein hochrangiger manager
und enger vertrauter von winterkorn
wir haben beschissen beweisaufnahme
abgeschlossen
keine weiteren fragen und nebenbei gab
es ja auch gerade noch das verfahren
gegen vorstandchef gis und chefaufseher
putsch wegen marktmanipulation pts alter
ja ist allerdings gerade maximal uncool
zu ende gegangen verfahren eingestellt
gegen zahlung von 9 millionen euro durch
volkswagen
also einen freispruch zu sagen wir mal
dritter klasse von wegen wir haben den
anlegern gegenüber alles richtig gemacht
dabei hatten sie für diese behauptung
damals extra sogar einen roboter gebaut
die vorwürfe sind unbegründet die
volkswagen ag ist dementsprechend
weiterhin der festen überzeugung alle
kapitalmarktrechtlichen
informationspflichten erfüllt zu haben
systemfehler systemfehler versuche
neustart
guter vortrag insgesamt fiese wochen für
den volkswagen konzern
denn dann ist da ja auch noch dieser
internet spot für den neuen golf acht
ganz böser schützt und böser shitstorm
oder war das doch alles wieder kunst und
wir haben es nicht kapiert herzlich
willkommen zu 1000 völlig missglückte
meisterwerke mit till reiners
heute reden wir mal über große
videokunst
sie stammt aus dem legendären
performance kollektiv volkswahl wie
madrid oder dali stehen die wolfsburger
für zu realismus insbesondere zu realer
abgaswerte ihr neuestes werk trägt den
titel der neue golf ein geniestreich
denn es geht im video tatsächlich um den
neuen golf
aber was rede ich lassen sie es einfach
mal auf sich wird
[Musik]
der neue geist war da bleiben so viele
fragen offen vor allem warum in welcher
welt ist menschenwerk schnitten als
wären sie popel eine positive geste und
was hat das mit autos zu tun da muss es
doch ein brainstorming gegeben haben bei
dem das besprochen wurde
und da hat wohl einer gesagt leute ich
hab nur richtig gute idee wir stellen
das auto irgendwo hin und dann steht
eine weiße hand einen schwarzen mann in
ein gebäude und in der großen vw runde
haben offenbar alle gesagt ja das ist
genau das was wir über unser auto sagen
wollen
+ das liebevolle detail das erst beim
zweiten schauen ins auge fällt als
erstes fliegender buchstaben ins bild
aus denen sich wunderbar ein
rassistisches wort mit n bilden lässt
kleiner tipp es ist nicht das wort nase
das meisterwerk muss deswegen als teil
eines gesamtkunstwerks zusammen mit der
entschuldigung gedacht werden denn vw
hat blitzschnell schlecht reagiert zitat
wir sind völlig überrascht und
schockiert dass unsere instagram story
derart missverstanden werden kann
wie weiß muss man sein dass man sich
denkt jedoch nichts rassistisches so
mittlerweile haben sich aber
entschuldigt und das ganze soll restlos
aufgeklärt werden wahrscheinlich kommt
raus schuld sind dieselben drei
ingenieure die ganz allein die betrug
software entwickelt und heimlich in
millionen von autos eingebaut haben vw
ist nämlich eigentlich wieso einen
coworking space also alle arbeiten vor
sich hin
und keiner weiß was der andere macht und
hinten kommen manchmal autos raus oder
peinliche videos das kollektiv arbeitet
übrigens schon am nächsten kunst kracher
da geht es um einen konzern der
jahrelang ein ganzes land bescheid und
dann kommt die chefin von dem land und
schenkt den tätern zur belohnung eine
neue auto auf 3 4
und wenn sie erzählten sind gut so kunst
soll ja wütend machen
guten abend 1000 völlig missglückte
meisterwerke
mit till reiners was denn über meinen
arsch geigensolo war doch versprochen
ihr könnt ja in der zeit den kanal
abonnieren
[Musik]